all right Travolta 1980 come on doesn't
get much better than that mechanical
bull come on but our next guest is a
true Urban Cowboy Dylan Swearingen grew
up in a little town in New York called
piffard population 208. now you don't
often think of New York as the bull
riding capital of the world but last
year Swearingen was crowned world
champion
he joins me now all right dalen this is
my I honestly I interview a lot of
politicians this is my favorite
interview okay so this better be good
how the heck did you do this all right
what outside of Buffalo and then you end
up uh winning it all and that as I've
had a chance to watch a lot of bull
riding it is so exciting and so
dangerous and it terrifies me
oh yeah yes ma'am it's definitely you
know it's always entertaining there's
always
something new happening that's for sure
to win
at this level
in bull riding
I think I just you know there's a lot
more to Rodeo in New York than people
think of you know people think of the
city and everything but there's a lot of
rodeo outside of that and uh so my
family they
um oh like I just kind of grew up doing
it and uh I went to Texas
um to do it in high school and to do it
in college
um and then just kind of lived out here
and
um just kind of been doing it and
um just been around the right people and
uh it's a lot of getting thrown off and
getting back up but that's for sure
seems to be exploding in popularity the
CEO of the professional bull riding
writer saying recently that across three
events this weekend New York City
Portland and Lexington PBR had the
single biggest regular season weekend of
ticket sales and attendance in its
history across three cities they hosted
a total of 64
000 people watching
why is this growing in popularity
I think it's grown in popularity just
because I mean
this is a sport where it's Man versus
beast and like it's got to play out
however God wants it you know like
there's no whistle once that gate opens
anything can happen can be a great ride
um a good wreck you know the
possibilities are endless once that gate
opens all right what are you 23
how's your back
it's good I'm feeling good you're bad I
I'm just watching this every time I'm
already getting you know they're already
roping they've already everything but
when I'm watching the big bull riders
and I'm thinking the only thing I'm
thinking of lower back discs you know
neck and if you get trampled one time
the wrong way that I mean people don't
realize how incredibly dangerous it is
how much does the average bull weigh
the average bull probably weighs about
18 1500 pounds
um so they're definitely big and they're
way stronger than you think you know and
um they're incredible athletes
themselves and and what's the worst
injury you've ever received for all the
aspiring bull riders out there
you know I've been pretty healthy you
know like I've I've had some surgeries
and stuff and you know those are
probably like the longest setbacks and
stuff but I've been really fortunate of
surgeries for what you know don't make
me pull it out of you Dylan come on
surgeries for one surgery on my shoulder
my hip uh my foot my jaw
um I'm not laughing but you acted like
you've never been hurt jaw shoulder hip
not your teeth are fine I can see if you
you still smile is there one time I have
to ask you this because I've gotten up
close to these bowls they all look mean
to me I mean I'm an animal lover but
they all look terrifying and scary to me
do you ever get a sense when you when
you're when you finally sit on one that
this is going to be really bad this
one's really angry or no do they all
seem the same
no I mean these Bulls are bred to do it
like in the back you know like they know
that when their job is up and but you
know for my mentality I never get on one
and say oh crap you know like I never
you can't get on one of these animals
and have a doubt in your mind that it's
gonna go bad or something like that I
mean
I think for me that's just setting
yourself up for failure and I'm gonna
I'm gonna set myself up for something
good to happen
well thank God for the rodeo clowns
that's all I could say
teach you next where you where are you
competing next
um I'm gonna take a couple weekends off
uh I kind of have some trouble going on
with my groin right now
um but it'll probably be in Duluth
Georgia
um in the the following weekend all
right we'll take care of that injury and
Dale and Swearingen what an amazing
story it is it is one of the coolest and
most unlikely of bull riding stories and
we wish you the very best
congratulations on all your success at
such a young age
thank you man hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else